imagine if you went to buy a car but all
the prices on the lot were kept hidden
from you it's not until after you sign
the paperwork drive the car home and
then you get a bill in the mail they
finally found out how much you're on the
hook for insane right well that's
basically how our medical system works
it's very rare for a hospital to tell
you up front what the costs of treatment
or procedures will be most patients are
in no position to haggle or shop around
so they pretty much have to say yes to
whatever's recommended and then wait for
a bill and have no way of knowing
whether it's accurate or Fair unlike
most developed Nations America has very
few regulations on medical pricing in
fact it's estimated that 75 to 80
percent of medical bills contain at
least one error that's why you should
always ask for an itemized Bill and
verify whether you actually received
every service on it and if you can try
to get a quote for the procedure
beforehand there may be some room for
negotiation believe it or not